[Music]
there's a film playing across the street
it's playing at five we can make it
there's gonna be five minutes of
trailers I want to get a good seat you
know a good seat from which to watch
Asgard burn let's show some movies
we're here to Heckle a movie 75 cents so
what actually happens those movies are
dreams but you never forget please
retain your stubs The Refreshments are
right over there hey uh do you want
anything of course butter plane extra
butter some Diet Coke please
[Music]
not bad seats at all
I miss the real change
sounds like a comedy it's a comedy it's
sexy and it's action
gotcha total entertainment experience
[Music]
thank you
did you see that I gotta see it again
Ernie
[Music]